it's the news no one wanted to hear the
discovery of a new covet variant called
omicron first identified in south africa
has hit world stock markets as concerns
grow about a new global threat the world
health organization has labelled it a
variant of concern based upon the
information that we have particularly
from south africa
they have advised who that this variant
should be classified as a variant of
concern so today we are announcing
b11529 as a variant of concern named
omicron the who cautioned against hasty
countermeasures for now but many
governments chose instead to act fast
early indications show
this variant may be more transmissible
than the delta variant and current
vaccines may be less effective against
it
it may also impact the effectiveness of
one of our major treatments ronald reef
the uk has led by restricting travel
from six southern african countries with
the eu urging all member states to
follow suit cases of the new variant
have been confirmed in a growing list of
countries including hong kong israel and
belgium
it is now important that all of us in
europe act very swiftly the european
commission has today proposed to member
states
to activate the emergency brake on
travel from countries in southern africa
and other countries affected of course
travel restrictions are designed not to
halt the spread of the variant it's too
late for that but instead to buy time
this new variant is has got the most
mutations that we've ever seen on
coronavirus so 30 more compared to the
original strain and about twice as many
as delta it will take weeks to know all
of that information and we know that
from
previous studies on alpha and delta that
it takes time to understand transmission
infectiousness it takes time to
understand the severity
in the weeks ahead the world will hold
its breath waiting to find out whether
the new variant is a dark turn in the
pandemic or a false alarm
nadim baba al-jazeera